[Music]
we are here to talk about the tournament
thanks to the Audi q8 which carlos and i
have the pleasure of driving it's
performance and design gives it a really
good commanding presence which is very
fitting given the basketball legends I'm
sitting here with today I'm excited
each year you get opportunity to see
something different it's unpredictable
that's why I think it's the best time of
the year for sports because the kids
truly determined who's gonna be the
champion tell me your favourite
tournament performances that you've seen
me I have a little bias I have to say it
comes from you comic country just you
would say you know just what Kimber did
he went on the run from the Big East
tournament all the way to win a national
championship that's what the tournament
is all about because you see so many
good teams but ultimately those good
teams has one or two good players on it
that helped them get to that front at
the time of the year which begs the
question what teams do you think you
know are designed if there any Duke to
go all the way I think I'd say I think
Duke I know we got a great chance we got
a great mixture of young talent still
coached by Coach K but a team I've been
I've been watched a little bit more
Virginia and Tennessee they got a couple
of upperclassmen they played very well
together they've got the system down and
don't sleep on Gonzaga exactly looks
very good to tell me this - what about
coaching cuz you add Coach K you had Jim
Calhoun
I had Lu ya the great thing about coach
is what we talked about we're talking
about right now is experience right so
these guys have seen so many different
players so many different teams so many
different guys come through and so many
different situations so when they see it
now I say 2019 this tournament something
will happen and we'll be able to adjust
on the fly because he has so much
experience something back on but he has
a great coaching staff and the other
thing about Coach K is he's always
innovative he's always calling out to
the other coaches in the NBA and
difficult even a football like Belichick
so good friend is get different ideas on
team concepts and he implements that
what
new group and the great thing about it
is he's able to get all these young kids
to be on the same page after the same
goal in a short period of time so too
when it's idle speaking of young kids
yeah Diane Williamson if you were at the
hype is he gonna live up to the hype
that we have was I am yeah we're gonna
find out he's on a special man I mean
we've seen some guys me and JT were
talking off air mark stottlemyre Blake
Griffin and Shawn Kemp like the rain
that rainy or days or back in the days
those guys are very similar was I was
able to do the differences I was like
285 yeah yeah oh he's built like a like
alignment in football and he's still
getting that big old body up there doing
all that crazy stuff so I think I think
his ability is through the roof
I think his talent level is very good I
think he's still learning how to play
basketball like to be smooth at it but
his his athleticism we haven't seen like
that at that weight before but have you
guys ever seen someone else for that
kind of commanding presence on the court
at 18 years old well he certainly has a
big body and you think about if we came
in typically most of us at that aid to
be coming to league and we were very
slim and yeah and everybody's like can
your body hold up yeah so we know in the
tournament there's there's those
defining moments of the tournament so to
speak I think back at the tournament
when I was coming up and and Bryce Drew
shot what a team prays oh yeah it's like
why are they even in a tournament first
of all I've never even heard about
pounds on until we seen him hit that
shot right so those are the type of
defining moments that the tournament is
just to me that's what draws you to it
and this is how the determinant works
you know the teams that did you know you
walk in with this bravado and it's just
arrogance that you know this team is the
ninth seed they don't stand a chance but
remember they just got the speech of
their lifetime in the locker room yeah
yeah the number two number one seat is
over here like guys you know we're gonna
have dinner tonight
we're gonna get ready for the next scene
the next day like that's the mentality
do you like upsets okay or do we feel
like it should be about the best team
winning that no I know that's
like like UPS you know why because
that's what makes it the tournament's
all amazing because you like my gray
said you may have a number one seat at
everybody sound they're gonna they're
gonna be in the championship series
they're gonna have a chance to win the
whole thing and all of a sudden here
comes a baler or a George Mason or
George Mason out of nowhere who got
veterans and seniors and upperclassmen
who played together who are tough were
experienced and they knock off these
young talent for me I mean the main bust
up your bracket a little bit but it
makes the tournament so much more it's
only one game ultimately what you see is
that the it's evenly matched because now
with so many players that leave you you
see a major college program with
freshmen and sophomores leading to him
at the helm and then in a mid-major you
see four seniors yeah well that five
senior Laden team ultimately is a more
experienced more skilled basketball team
so it's not really an upset when you see
it happen it's a team that's you know
meant to be there how do you guys feel
about one and Dunn's do you feel like
it's that should be the system yeah I
mean I think for me I just think it's is
there are certain guys that can handle
the one-and-done because you know you
got to be 19 years old going into the
next level and you're an adult you got
to pay taxes you gotta you got to find
out what you're gonna do with life after
practice every day as we all went
through we were a little older a little
mature oh you went through it but when
you're 19 years old you go to practice
for three hours that one o'clock you're
done with your day you got to go figure
out what else you got to do and it makes
you grow up a little faster now I'm not
saying that every one-and-done can't
handle that I just think the majority of
them need another another year next year
even to the mature your body to be more
physically ready but there are some guys
like you look at some guys that have
come in to the next level that we're
totally prepared out of high school you
think about LeBron or like a Kevin
Garnett or there are certain guys that
can handle it but the numbers you think
about the numbers they're very small who
do you got gotten y'all brackets this
year make a noise and or descender
brothers out there
I always put Michigan State in there I
don't care whose only 10 so final
finds a way to compete and be there in
the end
and so I always put Michigan State in
there now Cinderella I couldn't tell you
I don't know when she gonna show up to
the dance I just don't it's just
that's why she's Cinderella yeah and I'm
gonna go opposite you I'm gonna say
Michigan they they played they have a
lot of I think future pros on the team
you don't really know until it's all
said and done but they run sets like a
protein you know in wrong picking roles
they got shooters spacing on the
perimeter and it just seems like they
know how to play the game and they know
how to manage the game but my Cinderella
this year I got to go up Murray State
Kyle we talked about those players they
carry teams in the tournament he's gonna
be one of those guys that's gonna carry
his team because the other team is gonna
see Murray stayed on the roster and
they're gonna say what time is dinner
night you know I'm ready you know for
the next team and they're gonna sleep
while nothing he's gonna be a team he's
gonna be a player and a team that's
coming surprised some teams do have that
one special player remember Wally
Szczerbiak oh yeah carried that team how
serious you guys get with your brackets
and you're feeling them know the
tradition it yeah what do you do yeah I
do normal Braga's but I never won though
I mean I got like I got close I got like
top four or five but I never won the
whole thing
yeah used to always be to do they don't
even watch college basketball and we're
like dirt dirt the one three out of
eight years I played with him I'm like
their uni watch always win system he
just wrote in whatever he was like oh he
got over oh yeah oh Kentucky recruited
me but I didn't go but yeah let me get
them okay at the end do we find the best
team or do we find the best team that
day if I think there's a difference yes
a difference I think it's the best team
that day I see like four short hundred
percent and even more so the the team
that's playing well
at that particular the hottest team for
that you stretch right you can have
periods throughout the season where you
get hot and go ten you know right but in
the tournament is six games can you get
hot for six and and I think that's the
kind of thing we lived on it's like we
finished fit in our conference but we
still got a tournament bit and we're
like it's one game at a time
yeah then we won again then we won again
okay let's get to the next weekend and
now it's two games left and it's like
okay let's beat this team we get to the
championship anybody can win regardless
of what school or who where you came
from it's like you said can you get hot
at that particular time I was thinking
about that and it poses a new question
is because the bracketing is so super
important because you know that
selection Sunday we're all sitting
around but the coaches are always mad
mistakes was when we want a Big East
championship we we used to always say
we're not gonna celebrate we're not
gonna cut the Nets down we're gonna wait
and and one of the you know when I look
back on and I was like wow we didn't
enjoy that moment you know enjoy that
moment you know once you enjoy it cut it
down and then just let it be and then
move on to next you have some closure we
never had that closure and you know I
never won while I was there so it does
it does it is something about now
everybody on this dis chase for this
individual trophy regardless of where
you come from regardless of what part of
the country and you everybody's gonna
meet somewhere in the middle if you had
if you're good in this next month and I
think that's where America falls in love
with basketball
you know reinvigorates that love for
because you you don't just you're not
privy to the power five conference teams
you get to see the stories because you
know you see I don't know what the
school was add the the none that used to
follow around yeah like those stories
are their human stories their American
stories and people say to themselves
Wow like I love this woman I love this
team and look where they come from and
this is so like such an American story
that I want to be part of this to
underdog for America no story's out
because you wouldn't see Loyola Chicago
no and we all fell in love with that
story I mean we were almost rooting for
them because of just the story and you
think that in America we like to know
that everybody has a shot yeah no either
one at and redemption or just a success
you know just to be able to get to have
that top level and the college
basketball shows that that one time we
see do can we see Arizona and all these
schools and every year their perennial
they're there but now who else do we get
to see it we get to root on it and in
most of us big school guys we'd love to
see those school because it what it does
it makes all of us honest and that is
ultimately what the term is all about is
their BIOS opportunity
[Music]